oui il va regarder il prend ma main
après
l'Italie la différence
il ne s'interdire rien il est féroce
même avec ses meilleurs amis et pourtant
tous ne jurent que par lui grâce à lui
ce soir je reçois des invités de
prestige Johnny Hallyday bonsoir vous
allez vous allez je vais mieux je suis
très content d'être avec vous Mireille
merci moi de même Céline
je suis tellement contente avec vous à
soi surtout que j'ai deux heureux
événements j'en ai une paire comme mon
mari René Nicolas Sarkozy toujours
débordant d'activités
pour qu'on évoque les choses qu'elle me
manque sans clapotis dans le calme Vie
privée vie publique ça me concerne Jack
Lang un peu plus de temps libre oui
malheureusement quand j'attendais un
poste avec le dernier remaniement est
que nenni peau de balle alors je viens
ici pour faire ma promotion et je
demande à François Fillon de me trouver
un poste dans le prochain embalibre
bonsoir Laurent Gerra merci pour ces
imitations
voilà exactement mission trop nombreux
pour que franchement je les énumère
ces personnages c'est vrai que je me
réveille souvent avec des chansons des
personnages que j'ai mite ils me suivent
en tournée depuis une vingtaine d'années
maintenant j'ai toujours été avec eux ça
fait partie de ma ville musicaux et
c'est vrai que j'ai eu l'occasion de
rencontrer beaucoup il y en a beaucoup
qui sont venus voir mon spectacle en
plus oui avant de devenir la star de
limitation que l'on connaît aujourd'hui
Laurent Gerra a débuté sur la scène d'un
cabaret lyonnais l'accessoire a tout
juste 20 ans
[Musique]
le voyou
de ma carrière vous avez pu suivre mon
itinéraire à 24 ans il monte à Paris il
est rapidement repéré par Jacques Martin
maintenant il paraît qu'en bas on a
invité Madonna
achète sur scène
et il n'a rien dans le citron moi ça me
file des boutons qu'on prenne les gens
pour des cons
à 7 sur 7 et c'est en 1994 chez Michel
Drucker en duo avec celle qui à l'époque
partage sa vie Virginie Lemoine que la
France entière va l'adopter la
première Miss Patricia
[Applaudissements]
bonjour Patricia bonjour Jean-Pierre
Laurent Gerra ne s'interdit rien et tout
le monde est susceptible d'en prendre
pour son grade c'est Michel Drucker qui
s'excuse à sa place
[Musique]
il en est resté un célèbre gimmick
johnny c'est de l'humour et plus d'amis
que d'ennemis
mais finalement oui parce que comme
j'aime le musical on se l'est déjà dit
plusieurs fois en tout cas les gens qui
aiment le musical
sont obligatoirement admiratifs de des
grands artistes donc Johnny même si je
me suis moqué de lui au début et c'est
vrai que Michel a eu vraiment la
trouille parce que Johnny voulait lui
casser la gueule mais une fois qu'on
s'est rencontré avec Johnny il a vu
toute l'admiration il a pu mesurer toute
l'admiration que j'avais pour lui
dites-moi est-ce que vous vous trouvez
différents vous du justement de ce jeune
garçon qui a commencé à quel âge à 20
ans à peine sur les planches
je suis plus heureux maintenant
je suis toujours étonné d'avoir des
traits d'être encore ici et durée c'est
ça c'est l'école de Michel Drucker c'est
c'est la durée c'est il avait dit dans
le m’avait dit dans ce métier c'est duré
mais surtout c'est les rencontres que
j'ai faites dans ce métier qui vous a le
plus marqué
Jacques Martin parce que je me souviens
ça a été fait tellement rapidement
c'était mon papa de télé et puis Michel
c'est à dire Jacques Martin et Michel
mais avoir la vie de grands
professionnels c'est toujours
intéressant ça fait avancer Charles
Aznavour qui est dû voir mon spectacle
Olympia il m'avait fait une remarque un
jour je lui dis vous savez Charles j'ai
retenu ce que vous m'avez dit
il y a trop de c'est trop long entre les
sketchs il y a trop de noirs les noirs
sont trop longs alors là du coup je suis
tout le temps sur scène j'ai dit c'est
grâce à vous Charles donc vous l'avez
écoutez
tu force trop j'entends il faut chanter
avec le ventre avec le ventre oui parce
que tu es si tu vas voir tu vas gagner
vachement de puissance
et c'est vrai j'ai jamais fait de gros
nichons
et le conseil de Jacques Martin il
m'avait dit un jour quelque chose
d'assez étrange que Bouvard m'avait dit
aussi un jour tu arrêteras de faire des
imitations parce que quand on fait des
imitations c'est les autres qu'on
applaudit j'ai jamais été vraiment
d'accord avec lui non parce qu'on a une
façon de le faire on a une façon de
faire du music-hall et il a dit non non
c'est pas toi qu'on applaudit ces
suicide parfois c'est vrai écoutez là
tout semble vous réussir là franchement
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina
Mireille Dumas abonnez-vous et activez
la cloche
[Musique]